Speaker 1: So after his completely farcical
presidential announcement on Twitter spaces,
Florida Republican Governor Ron DeSantis gave
his first interview as a presidential candidate.
He gave this interview to Trey Gowdy, who
was guest hosting on Fox News.
And DeSantis suffered what I call a talking
point coma.
He couldn't stop repeating the word woke.
He also threw in an anti-Semitic conspiracy
theory for good measure.
Right.
I mean, he is running as a Republican after
all.
Let's take a look at this.
And this is just if you thought the announcement
was bad.
When DeSantis actually gets a chance to speak,
it gets even worse.
So let's start there.
Here is Ron DeSantis with a talking point.
Coma can't stop saying woke.
Speaker 2: Well, first of all, the woke mind
virus is basically a form of cultural Marxism.
At the end of the day, it's an attack on the
truth.
And because it's a war on truth, I think we
have no choice but to wage a war on woke.
So how does that work for a president?
Some of it may be the bully pulpit being willing
to tell the truth and not being deluded by
ideology, which we see in many aspects of
our society.
Speaker 1: There you go.
So woke, woke, woke.
Florida is where woke goes to die.
We will end woke.
So please understand that the term cultural
Marxism is nothing but a far right wing conspiracy
theory.
That is.
Let me too.
To put it lightly, often tinged with anti-Semitism,
I get emails every time one of these right
wingers starts talking about cultural Marxism.
People write and say, David, what the hell?
I know Marxism.
The economic theory.
What on earth is cultural Marxism?
When the right uses the term cultural Marxism?
They are talking about a supposedly leftist
agenda that wants to undermine traditional
values.
It wants to erode societal norms.
It wants to promote political correctness
and police, police speech and this sort of
thing.
Often what they accuse George Soros of is
tantamount to the very cultural Marxism they
claim exists.
And they say that this so-called cultural
Marxism is a conspiracy propagated by left
wing intellectuals, left wing activists, Democrats,
etc.
They want to infiltrate and control institutions,
including academia, media, entertainment,
and they want to reshape culture to fit their
ideology.
Now, according to that perspective, cultural
Marxists are accused of manipulating language,
promoting and using identity politics, advocating
for social justice issues and LGBT rights
and so on and so forth, at the expense of
individual freedoms and liberty and so on
and so forth.
The most important thing to understand about
so-called cultural Marxism is that it essentially
does not exist.
And what I mean by that is Marxism focuses
on economic structures and class struggle.
That's the first thing to understand.
It doesn't actually focus on cultural or social
issues, although Marxism does acknowledge
that culture and society will be shaped by
the economic system.
That's number one.
So even the term doesn't really make sense.
Secondly, the entire emergence of the term
cultural Marxism came from a misinterpretation
of actual Marxism.
That's number two and the number three.
There's also no Marxists in the United States.
Now, I know you might go to, you know, the
local Magic the Gathering tournament and meet
an actual Marxist who understands Marxist
ideology and says they subscribe to it.
And I'm not insulting magic the gathering.
I'm just saying you might be able to find
someone somewhere who's actually a marxist.
There is not a single Marxist in a position
of power in federal government that I can
think of in the United States.
So when the right talks about cultural Marxism,
they don't even really know what they're talking
about.
It's not Marxism, it doesn't exist, and it's
thinly veiled anti-Semitism.
So but that wasn't the worst moment of this
entire thing.
Then DeSantis is asked, What makes you different
than Trump?
When Nikki Haley was asked this question,
she said, I'm a woman of color and I'm younger.
When Tim Scott was asked What makes you different
from Trump?
He didn't even really answer.
And he said, There will be a stark contrast
by which I guess he means he's younger than
Trump and he's black.
Does Ron DeSantis actually answer the question?
Let's see.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
So why now?
And what distinguishes you from the other
candidates?
Are there policy differences or is it more
about electability and how you would implement
those policies even if you agree on them?
I don't know.
Well, why now?
I think it's because the country is going
in the wrong direction.
We have another four years of the Biden administration.
I think some of the damage is going to be
irreversible.
I think we have an opportunity now, kind of
like the late 1970s when Jimmy Carter was
president, to really move the country in a
much stronger direction and really bring a
lot of bold leadership to bear.
Why me?
Well, I think what we've been able to do in
Florida is two things.
One, we've had an unprecedented policy success.
All the things that we believe as Republicans
or as conservatives for many, many years,
we've been able to take those values and those
principles and actually turn them into reality.
Every single day we put up big wins on the
board, but we're doing that while also enjoying
major political success.
You alluded to it.
We were able to win reelection by a historic
margin.
Speaker 1: So as you can see, he doesn't actually
say what distinguishes him from Trump when
he was asked about the military and exactly
what he would do with Ukraine.
He talked about gender ideology.
I'm not kidding, guys.
I'm not kidding.
Look at this.
Speaker 2: All right.
You wore the uniform.
If you are elected president, you may be the
first one in a while to have worn the uniform.
How would you address the ongoing war in Eastern
Europe between Russia and Ukraine on day one
of his presidency?
Speaker 1: Good question.
Speaker 2: Well, first, I think what we need
to do as a veteran is recognize that our military
has become politicized.
You talk about gender ideology.
You talk about things like global warming
that they're somehow concerned about.
That's not the military that I served in.
We need to return our military to focusing
on commitment, focusing on the core values
and the core mission.
Wow.
That would be something that I could take
care of on day one.
There will be a new sheriff in town as commander
in chief, and I think you'll see recruiting
start to get back to where it needs to be
because people don't want to join a war as.
Speaker 1: If the military is not big enough
of.
Speaker 2: Military.
And I think it's been really, really problematic.
Look, in terms of what's going on over in
Eastern Europe, you know, I'd like to see
a settlement of this.
I do not want to see a wider war.
Speaker 1: Okay.
So what he would do it?
He would he wants the war to end is what he
would do.
But woke in the military is really the problem.
Disastrous interview.
Is that going to convince MAGA voters to switch
to de Santos from Trump?
Let's give it a few days and see where the
polling lands